es kommt ja schon gezeigt dass wir zu
produktiv sind ja dazu damals war ich
fast das komplette outfit
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft war oh ich
komme ich auf den server ich schon du
schon ich schon ich komme nicht drauf
das machen wir denn jetzt hat das ist ja
also ich bin ja jetzt schon im studio
ich muss ja auch auf dem leaderboard
schon drin
ich bin ja jetzt schon drin genauso im
moment stadt ist aber nicht so gut
machen und guck mal hier oben ist noch
einer das heißt wir haben noch genügend
sich über ich habe gehört dass eine ich
war also hallo schön
ihr habt dann rat vorhin können wir das
eventuell einwenden dass sich einfach
dein bild ganz kurz
ich habe auch gedacht dass er einfach
immer die kohle abbauen leiste nicht mit
einer spitzhacke aber mit der zeit
einfach falls herr erfahrung ist ja ja
ja ja
also zurück zu meinem plan ich werde
jetzt hoch gehen wie eine einzige machen
und dann den diamanten abbauen mit
diesem diamanten werde ich dann
möglichst bald einen strandhotel machen
konnte schon obsidian geformt und dann
brauchen wir doch bücher und dann sind
wir für die ober kings und kreise im
land wirklich mal eine geile basis
machen eine richtig irgendwie am himmel
oder so dann bauen uns einfach mit
obsidian einer kampfsituation wir nicht
wollen dass eine rein kommenden jahr ab
und ja ich sag mal was ja kontinents
kennst du kennst du das gefühl wenn du
noch in der wandel zu finden nein wenn
du wenn du das klo zu müssen aber nicht
muss kennst du nicht mehr direkt über
mir aber ich komm ja gar nicht hoch weil
ich mich voll verrechnet in deinen
scheiß tunnel ihr das ist das gut meine
gegner reinkommen die wahl auch wenn
marcel aber auch ich mag man hier
einfach alles rüber über drüber
ach ja stimmt und was ich machen wollte
war ein feuerzeug flynn und stil für pvp
wir werden unsere seite zu senden du
hast doch viel zu sehr angst korridors
viel zu sehr angesagt wo ich habe mich
verlaufen ich bin bereits gelaufen super
schön schön also ägypten bangen muss
einfach die erzählt einnahm ich gehe die
abholen kind hin sehr schnell die
resignieren
jetzt hoffe ich sie dann 1 1 1 bleibt
stehen wo du warst ja cool hier kommen
hier hoch da hab ich ja ja ja ja also
ich bin los bei dir alter das wollte ich
kann und ich habe gedacht mach' ich das
nicht und du halt die gewisses extra
dich auch ich so dass es war egal egal
so gut ich kann oberfläche holen uns ein
bisschen bücherregal müssen ich muss da
muss ich nicht lange
ich habe mir die koordinaten
aufgeschrieben oder diamant ist und das
ist auch gut so
ja nicht dass jetzt einfach mal so ein
wassereimer ja material also ein eimer
und hole dann wasser und dann mache ich
und meine kleine nichte eventuell und
ziehen das heißt es bringt gar nichts
wenn all das ich reiße skelette was geht
denn locator ist eine klasse sache sind
das hat sich so viele gewünscht und ich
dachte vielleicht klappt das ja ich da
ein bisschen auf den auf den du bist zu
hause wie hast du das denn wie hast du
das denn gemacht hast deine kamera weg
kommen muss man da machen aber du bist
doch also man wenn man sich anschaut
denkt man ja ja diagnose bis gebot aber
wenn man heute die angst ist gut so
jetzt aber die rezitatorin sagen wollte
ja und zwar gehe ich jetzt was soll ich
sagen
es bringt gar nichts wenn ihr jetzt
irgendwie mir sagt soja guck mal hier
die koordinaten da sind ja so und so und
da sind die da müssen wir unbedingt
hingehen unseren scheiß
das bringt gar nichts weil wir jetzt
drei folgen am stück aufnehmen
das heißt in der folge die übermorgen
kommt sind wir hier gar nicht mehr am
start also mir dann irgendwo anders
die folge das seht wenn irina wieder
sind dann sehen bis dahin wieder
umgezogen und ich habe das glück immer
wenn ich rausgehe es macht das ist das
ist das ist das ist das ist toll
wir können ja herr bergmann und den
danach machen du rennst einfach die
ganze zeit durch die gegend und lässt
sich halt bin ich in einer
kampfsituation bin und mir hat einfach
endlos weiter aufnehmen
ich fand das lustig sehr einfachen 20
sekunden 20 sekunden und drei minuten
so also habe ich schon am stück ich gehe
auch aus weil ich habe eigentlich jetzt
hier das ist nacht lassmann panel robin
wenn du dir wolle da hab ich doch am
kant wolle da oder das obsidian wir
müssen halt jetzt möglichst wir müssen
jetzt einfach mal ab zehn jahren
schlafen legt dann wenn ich schon mal
wenn wir wenn ihr bücher kriegen mein
freund und kupferstecher dann könnt ihr
uns damit schon mal die sachen auf level
verzaubern ohne bücherregale weil
einfach nur das geht übrigens ich war
hier zu wenig platz für den baum ist
mein freund
was wollt zu machen dass man einfach
ausgehen
ja okay ich dachte schon mal so einen
tisch machen ja aber klar aber dafür
brauchen wir papier und also aus dem
papier bücher zu machen und dafür müssen
wir wollen dingsda sammeln hier kripo
friedberg reaper ich hab' ich habe das
ungute gefühl so wir gehen jetzt mal
raus nach guck mal da ist schon das
schön
wir gehen jetzt mal raus kommen die wir
sind jetzt wir sind uns mal knüppelhart
du kannst uns ja du wir haben voller
rüstung da sollte nichts passieren
eine wasserquelle da und in unseren
kleinen bruder übrigens wurde uns ja
geschrieben also ihr seid ja sehr sehr
zuträglichen kommentar es hier in der
nähe irgendwo also dass viele teams
eigentlich ein hus gelitten kommt also
kilowatt ist denn wirklich sehr zäh los
mit dir dass du hast so alles und hinten
jedoch schon wieder die sonne auf
menschen vor einem skelett jörg thoma
das laut klatsch klatsch ich mit mit mit
links klatsche ich das weg also da mache
ich heute gebiet der der trainiert auch
nur bizeps deswegen kann er das einfach
so leicht weg schlagen
das ist das gar kein gar kein ding ja
ich habe jetzt mal übrigens eine
wasserquelle gemacht die wir jetzt hier
unten haben das ist du du bist mal
wieder also du bist eine ich bin so das
ist krass das kann man jetzt bei
rauskommt dann heißt das wir nicht
zufolge sterben die glaub ich kann es
jetzt ich glaube ich kann uns ein
shampoo table machen also ohne witz ich
glaube ich könnte es wirklich war war
ich glaube ich kann es tatsächlich einen
machen ich würde hat gesagt wenn
herauskommt dann stell mir nächste folge
was kamerun
nun ich bin so unglaublich gut alter ist
nicht mehr normal dass sich das kräftige
rezept auswendig gelernt ab hallo du
bist so dass wir einfach hierhin satz
wurden nicht nur die was ist weil ja
aber du kannst ja abbauen den auch
wieder duh hält ja dieses huhn das macht
mir voll angst weil ich habe einfach
gesagt dass wieder nächsten folge
sterben aber jetzt verzaubert einen
ganzen stoff auf level 1 versorgung
level 2 willst du eine ahnung von dem
schatz ich verzaubert mal niemals wert
noch nicht erst mal meine damen bot das
level 1 okay hier das ist einfach mal
schutz 1 weil irgendwie ist wenn wenn
man die
bücherregale leute in die kommentare
geschrieben dass das dann schlechte
verzauberung werden können und das
wollen wir natürlich nicht
ich habe schon meine schuhe verzaubert
ja warum science oder ja jetzt nämlich
geradezu aber gerade alles mal auf level
1 jetzt habe ich schon verzauberte
rüstung was sind wir für andere sommer
und der glp das glaub ich auch schon
verfasst sodass schon mal schon mal ganz
cool aber das schwert kann ich hier nur
auf level 2 verzaubern uns erstmal mit
dem schwert das geht das einst so zac
münchen wir brauchen haben für meine
eltern sind auf wahre ich sollte auch
wenn der fahrer durch die gegend war ja
wann schwert schäfer 10 einfach ein halb
schaden obwohl ich hier bin ich wohl
noch ein bisschen mehr hier ja ja ja ich
kenne ja alle bücher es ist ja auch mein
tag ich muss mal ein bisschen rumlaufen
das haben die leute auch gestiegen leute
laufen ein bisschen wir einfach suchen
ich brauch mal was zu essen ich hab gar
nichts zu essen kinos wie war das doch
leider ist es auch wenn wir eventuell
zusammen um neue ideen spinnen spinnen
kümmern bogen machen spinnen spinnen
spinnen würde es los mit uns ja mal gar
nichts zu essen hier internet angemeldet
bin ich bin an der wand meint ja ich hab
es natürlich komme
wieviel 15 gebratenem fleisch immer
sieben mach da da da übrigens auch eine
zusatzinformation wenn ich jetzt fleisch
ist ja und nur 1 lehr habt dann ist das
nicht so dann wird das gespeichert
obendrüber auch soweit ich weiß man in
euren version so dass die wand jako o
gott die risiken stephan weil freunde
man konnte alles aber einfach mal alles
abschlachten ein bisschen am besten
richter in diamant schwertner stimmt das
gericht nimmt am besten an eisen
schwerter obwohl ihr können auch
reparieren was so viele level wie der
name ja du aber besser wir geben die
levels claudio ricci ich glaube hier
kann das sein dass ich glaube da ist
hier in seiner folge runtergefallen das
sieht irgendwie ähnlich aus hier wie was
ich hab keine ahnung also ich schaue auf
folgen von anderen an bisschen die schau
man noch ein bisschen rein bin ja ich
richtig also alle anschauen geht ja auch
kaum also das kriegt man ja schlecht auf
die kette so viel gar keine erfahrungen
lasst uns einmal vor die wand ein foto
ins feld die vorderwand machen euch ja
dafür da waren wir natürlich zeit also
es ist ja auch es kommt ja schon gezeigt
dass wir zu produktiv sind ja das war
irgendwie weg wir co
but first world level des 11 warum
machen
warum der nicht nur war etwas was sind
eigentlich was ist unser plan wir wollen
mal was mal wenn wir jetzt umziehen
jetzt schon wie ich würde sagen wir
suchen noch so ein bisschen mops sollen
wir noch mehr diamanten ich kann noch
mal auf diamanten suche gehen oder ich
suche so ein bisschen so bobs und so
einen scheiß halten
fleisch die stars und du gehst nach
unten so ist diamanten und ich sogar
noch bücher und eine spinne ich glaube
ehrlich genug von bogen
obwohl er damit auslösen um hier hinten
wir da hier waren da nicht da war da
doch da ist auch den angeschwemmt wurde
womit ich komme und zum anderen wir
müssen uns echt um mehr um essen das
könnte sein
da erwartet doch immer wieder waren ja
auch noch anfangen sollten
das hatte ich habe da wirklich nur
angeguckt und dann am anfang jetzt der
folge war halt wirklich an die welt als
sich irgendwie anders
diese
produktiv und sind wir heute auch
ehrlich aber heute habe ich ein bisschen
aber wir kümmern uns mal darum weil das
ja auch wir sind jetzt unterhalten
taktisch sinnvoll ist es ja eigentlich
auch das ist auf jeden fall ihr taktisch
sinnvoll
jeder ist eingeladen geschwommen wollte
er sieht irgendwas helles da hat er
wahrscheinlich etwas an der wand gesehen
oder irgendwie sowas ich weiß es nicht
das war auf jeden fall unser potenzial
hier und die schlägt zu
hier ist den anderen gelaufen und dann
hat er dort irgendwas gesehen und dies
und das und wir müssen uns wir müssen
uns vor allem in unserer nächsten basis
darum kümmern dass wir
hier diese sache machen mit weizen und
anbau und sowas gesprochen ob ich hier
noch irgendwas finden was mitzunehmen
ich könnte mal hier wo bist du denn
gerade im winter sind auch nicht ich
möchte dass du einfach wieder zurück
geht und so ein bisschen noch diamanten
als so wichtig und ich gucke einfach so
ein bisschen nach sicher bewertet werden
wer hat dir wer hat ihr werk die
bitteschön den anführer posten verpasst
du kannst du bist so gut im diamanten
suchen wir brauchen dich bei den
diamanten entstand dass ich auch nur bei
mir das ein richtiger richtiger schon
hören wenn ich so eine wand vor mir habe
fühle ich mich echt so zu hause fühle
ich mich einfach so richtig eingeengt
wenn man sich so überlegt so das ist
nicht frei hier
du wirst hier einfach und ich hab
einfach aus seit heute mittag und scheiß
maiskorn zwischen den zehen und das gibt
die ganze zeit so komisch okay
ja ich habe auch heute ist heute mittag
seinen hessischen penis ring zwischen
der rechten und der juden ganztagsschule
ich meinen freund natürlich dafür ja so
eindeutig mit dir ja längst auf jeden
fall nicht
ich hab ich eigentlich schon dabei ist
eigentlich dass du dich eigentlich
unsere tour so tun sollen weil ich
sterbe an dieser folge
das haben ja schon hast du auch die zeit
guckt ich habe wir haben noch drei
minuten locker hätten die anderen immer
die ideen die eigentlich am werk sagen
sagt 15 minuten jede folge zwei minuten
drüber oder drunter ist die toleranz
grenze aber eben trotzdem alle ernähren
sind zehn minuten offen da habe ich
wegen nachkommen wir haben immer bei 310
chf marke will ein bisschen mehr an die
so ein bisschen die an die an die
toleranz grenze heran preschenden auch
hier wieder bissig hier wieder unten bei
14 bin ich aber auch noch marco sturm ja
kann ich dir noch langlauf hast du kurz
gehen hier stinkt's ein bisschen mehr
inneres apps sind wer ist denn hier
bittet der olympia von uns beiden ja du
du also übrigens ja ich weiß es ist
ziemlich dunkel im eine episode ich
leuchte ab sofort öfter aus man legt
euch aber eine fehlgeburt hatte kritik
an
ich habe mir in wahrheit ein video von
die angekommene einmal beim ganzen leben
und ich hab nichts erkannt
ja es reicht um ein gesicht aus dem
gameplay sehen also einfach zu viele
forderungen als auch verdammt den sprung
nicht geschafft ja geil ich finde auch
einfach keine zuckerrohr
du bist also wie immer conny ist das
halt also eigentlich könnte ich auch
alleine spielen bringt da nix ich
bringen hier nichts
jetzt noch mit kind ihn sehen sollen
meine mama hat mir schon gesagt also
jedes projekt von erzähler wie gesagt
mit dem mit dem coni wird nix ich will
jetzt einfach mal zusammen
dann kann man ja wenn wir im notfall
auch irgendwie dann pflanzen ihr macht
das macht es doch mal haben doch
bestimmt auch ein paar knochen da wo man
klopfen wir das machen könnte oder ein
paar brote bernhard ganz ganz attraktiv
so jetzt manchmal als beim laufen auf
dem bildschirm ist es halt deutlich
heller deswegen youtube macht dass er
sowieso dass ein bisschen uncool
aber ich sorge mich erst seit zwei
monaten youtube youtube youtube dieses
youtube man ich suche die ganze riesen
pilze es gibt einen riesen pilz das im
gop und zombie poppig informiere ich
weiß das versuche ich den ja ist
abnormal wie informiert wir sind beide
arten von pilzen bisher gefunden und das
ist ja super
wir machen es einfach bildchen
bildschärfe hätten einfach so einem pilz
cool alter dann können uns einfach so
viele pilze machen so ein leckeres
süppchen so kleines zum schnabulieren
erhält die richtige paket sogar auf
einen echten leben nicht aus eine echte
schwierige pilzsuppe wurde der gestank
noch eine minute geht das noch okay du
musst das gut im blick haben ja ja ja
ich hab dazu weil man dafür diesem
projekt nicht zu oft verfehlen ansonsten
wird man höchstpersönlich von silber mit
seinen dreadlocks erwirkt das ist die
exakt formulierte strafe in den regeln
genau sie man kommt zu dir und dann
stoppt er hier so viele dreadlocks einem
und bis zur versteckst du also ich weiß
jetzt wieder nach hause finde das schon
hinkriegen ist einfach
vielleicht kommt da noch immer auf dem
server dann lassen wir es halt was hat
das gebilde nicht findest du zu ja ja so
ich muss aber auch mal gleich wieder
zurück in ruh ich will gerade war
erstmal hier schluss für heute hatte ich
die bewertung das ist euch hier gefallen
hat und dann ein bisschen morgen